alright hello everybody okay so this is
the fifth lecture of the class and today
we're going to talk a little bit more
about second-order ode e's and towards
the end of the class we're going to get
into kind of general high order OD es
with arbitrarily many time derivatives
okay
and towards the end of the lecture we
might get into some matrix systems of
differential equations and next week
we're gonna look at linear linear
systems of equations eigenvalues and
eigenvectors okay so just a quick
overview last time we looked at second
order systems of equations and we're
going to do that again today and in
particular we're going to look at
something called the characteristic
equation so how many of you kind of
remember hearing about this
characteristic equation at some point
how many of you have not heard of this
before okay probably a couple of you
we'll do a little bit of MATLAB and then
we'll get into higher order so next week
we'll deal with matrix systems of
differential equations so if I have a
vector X dot equals a matrix a times my
vector X maybe I have some initial
condition vector X knots we'll learn how
to solve these matrix systems of
equations using eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
okay I'm gonna be out of town on Monday
and so my TA Scott is going to be in
class on Monday doing a MATLAB review so
I know some of you probably are either a
little rusty on that lab or maybe you
haven't seen it before and so on Monday
he's gonna just go through a bunch of
stuff in that lab how to plot how to
simulate systems of OD ease how to you
know write a for loop and define a
vector and a matrix and just basic stuff
okay so it might be really useful for
some of you for others you might not
need it don't feel obligated to come and
some of you have asked me if there's a
good reference for MATLAB if you have
not used MATLAB before and so I'll point
to two things first there is this
excellent book by Nathan cuts over in
the applied math department okay
it's called data-driven modeling and
scientific computation methods for
complex systems and big data it's 42
dollars it's like a 600 page paperback
book it's now the most the most frequent
book I take off my bookshelf is this one
it's excellent excellent book it has
MATLAB code for all of the mathematical
techniques that he introduces from
numerical differentiation to numerical
integration to solving PDEs all kinds of
cool stuff we will cover a lot of
material that is very similar to this
book you don't have to buy it but I you
know would recommend it if you want to
learn more about MATLAB or if you think
you're going to do scientific computing
in the future it's fantastic okay so I
recommend this one more than the course
textbook pricing okay the other great
reference the other great reference for
anything in MATLAB is MATLAB if you
sorry someone needed this still just
Google Cutts data-driven modeling Amazon
and you'll find it
okay yeah the other probably I'm gonna
switch now the other best place to learn
about MATLAB is MATLAB so let's say you
want to know how to plot something you
type doc plot and this will bring up the
documentation for plots and it'll tell
you what types of arguments it takes all
of the different ways you can call the
plot command it will give you examples
so you click on the example button then
you see you know how you would actually
type in the lines of code to make a
plots and what the plot should look like
ok so this is how most of us learn
MATLAB is by coding in MATLAB just try
things out okay that's what I would
really recommend okay so I'm gonna do a
little bit of MATLAB later but to start
we're really gonna do some analytic
expressions with Odie's homework one is
due today there's now a box to submit
homework in the Emme front office so
we're all the homework submission
folders are there's one that says me5 64
so in the future you can just drop all
of the homeworks off there or email them
to me in the TA so that's also fine I
don't like rar files zip files are okay
PDFs are okay please don't send rar
files cuz I don't know how to unpack
them easily okay so we're going to keep
going with examples of second-order ODS
and we're going to build up kind of
general strategies to solve all linear
ordinary differential equations okay so
our example is X double dot plus three X
dot plus two x equals zero and what else
do I need to specify initial conditions
how many initial conditions do I need
for a second order linear differential
equation two okay so I'm going to make
them easy X zero equals two and X dot 0
equals minus three I could have other
initial conditions I could say like X
naught plus
X dot not equals 5 and X not minus X dot
not equals you know minus 5 I could I
could just make up any kind of linear
combination of these to specify initial
conditions but this is the easiest way
okay so I told you that we can always
solve differential equations using
Taylor series right and that's good to
know it's good to be able to derive e to
the lambda T and Coast and sine from
Taylor series but whenever you see a
simple linear ordinary differential
equation meaning that there's no
products of terms there's no X dot times
X's or X Squared's or X dot cubes or
anything like that this is just you know
linear coefficients of each of the terms
anytime you have a differential equation
like that you can always solve it using
either the lambda T always so doing the
Taylor series is like the laborious
difficult way of deriving e to the
lambda t for these simple linear cases
ok so we're going to assume that our
solution is X of T equals e to the
lambda T X dot equals lambda e to the
lambda T this is just review from last
time now we're gonna start plotting them
in MATLAB and really interpreting what
these lambdas mean X double dot is
lambda squared e to the lambda T and so
if I plug all of those in I have a
lambda squared e to the lambda T 3
lambda e to the lambda t + 2 e to the
lambda T so I have lambda squared plus 3
lambda plus 2 e to the lambda T equals 0
and remember e to the lambda T is always
positive and so the only way this can
ever equal 0 is if you have a lambda
that solves the root of this polynomial
so that's a lambda squared plus 3 lambda
plus 2 equals 0 this is a really really
really important polynomial it's called
the characteristic equation
and this tells us which land solve this
differential equation ok the roots of
this equation are the lambda that salt
my OD so this one's really easy we can
factor this right okay so it's lambda
plus 2 times lambda plus 1 equals 0 and
so what does that mean lambda equals
negative 1 or negative 2 okay so what is
my solution of this oh oh de going to
look like all right X of T equals what
some constant let's call it k1 yep e to
the minus T plus another constant k2 e
to the minus 2t okay that is kind of the
general solution of this OD e before
specifying initial conditions and now
that I know that I have initial
conditions I can plug those in so what's
X 0 of this equation K 1 plus K 2 and
what's X dot at 0 negative K 1 minus 2 K
2 and so I made this one really easy so
if k1 is equal to k2 is equal to 1 you
get these initial conditions
okay so we have k1 equals k2 equals 1
and so the actual solution is e to the
minus T plus e to the minus 2t
okay pretty straightforward right in
general if I gave you weird initial
conditions like X naught equals PI and X
dot naught equals minus 12 you would
actually have to solve this linear
system of equations for k1 and k2 right
so you could write this as a matrix and
invert the matrix or you could do it in
MATLAB and we'll do that next week okay
okay so what happens to this system what
happens to this equation for long times
as time goes to infinity what if my
solutions look like they go to zero
right they decay so e to the minus a big
number is really really close to zero
and both of these are minus exponents so
these are decaying to zero in
exponential time okay so we're gonna
plot this in MATLAB and we're going to
make sure that it's consistent with what
we think MATLAB is giving us so there's
another trick to solving this where we
can write this as a matrix system of
equations okay and that's what we're
eventually going to want to do for
linear systems that's kind of the most
general way of solving these and we
touched on this a little bit in the last
class so I can take this equation X
double dot plus three X dot plus two x
equals zero and I can do something
called suspending variables and it's
just a fancy way of saying that I'm
going to keep introducing new dummy
variables until I turn the second-order
linear system into two first order
coupled equations so I'm going to say X
dot equals some dummy variable V V is
usually for velocity and then V dots
should look like X double dot and it's
going to equal minus two X minus three X
dots minus two X minus three x dots and
what is X dot V
okay so this system of two first order
equations is exactly the same as this
single second order equation they're the
same mathematical entity they have the
same solution they mean the same thing
and so I can write this as a matrix so
DDT of this vector X position and
velocity is equal to a matrix 0 1 minus
2 minus 3 times my vector X V ok this is
a nice way of writing a system of
differential equations so I have a
vector dot equals a matrix times that
vector and in general if I had like a
fifteenth order equation with you know X
15th derivative plus a bunch of other
stuff I could add fifteen variables and
get a fifteen by fifteen a matrix to
represent that that differential
equation I can do this for any linear
differential equation at all and this is
going to be the preferred way of
entering these systems into MATLAB so
this is going to be useful for MATLAB
okay any questions before we start
plotting this stuff any questions at all
no yeah
for example and that you gave to it
secure initial condition is like the
variable you want to solve the different
equations for like I feel partly yeah so
let's say this X naught was a number a
and that it was a variable that could be
anything you choose you might want to
plug in 5 or 4 or 3 or 2 then you would
have that variable here and you would
represent k1 and k2 in terms of that
that variable initial condition and then
these variable constants you know if you
changed your initial conditions so X
naught was 5 instead of 2 then these K
ones and K choose would change
accordingly
you haven't you want to express that I'm
gonna plug in zoom this solution or
complex and this solution
yeah I mean so that's that's a good
question so sometimes when we like if I
change the sign of this I might get
complex solutions right I might get a
solution like minus one plus I times
time and so there's lots of ways of
interpreting this usually you think of
the real part as the position X and the
imaginary part is the velocity but
that'll become a lot more clear when I
write this as a matrix system okay
because we'll have complex eigenvalues
but our solutions for position and
velocity have to be real right a mass
can never have an imaginary position or
an imaginary velocity so the phase of
that complex number has to do with the
phase between position and velocity of
those sine waves so that's something
we'll get into a lot more it's a little
kind of conceptually tricky but you know
I think it'll make a lot more sense when
we do deal with matrices okay so this is
the equation we're dealing with I'm
going to first of all just plot the
analytic solution then I'm going to
simulate it in MATLAB and see if I get
the same solution okay and what's my
initial condition X naught V knots
just remind me two and negative three
okay so it's a vector to negative three
anyone know how to alright let's try it
again
gotta be gentle okay I didn't realize
how much I cuss under my breath until I
watched one of my videos okay can
everyone in the back see the screen yeah
okay okay so as always I clear all of
the memory I closed all my figures and I
clear the command window it's just a
nice way to start a MATLAB script okay
so I want to plot this from T equals
zero to ten increments of 0.02 so to use
a vector from zero to ten and it has
increments of 0.02 fine so to use a
vector of data and I'm going to say X
equals e to the minus T plus e to the
minus 2t I'm going to plot time versus X
in black okay good
looks like an exponential decay right I
start with my initial condition two and
very rapidly decays to something nearly
zero okay so now I'm going to hold on
and I'm going to instead of writing down
the analytic solution I'm going to
simulate that system in MATLAB using
ode45 so OD 45 is just a fancy very
accurate numerical integrator it solves
using the runge-kutta fourth-order
scheme will talk a little bit about that
later so we need to define an initial
condition so Y naught equals to 3 a
vector 2 then minus 3 we have an a
matrix which is 0 1 minus 2
- 3 and we have OD 45 suit so it's going
to give me an output of a vector of time
that it evaluates and then this vector
of y/y has two states so there's going
to be position and velocity okay Y is
going to have two column vectors that's
going to equal OD e45 of I have to
define a function the right-hand side of
my vector field so y dot equals a times
y this is my right-hand side function
okay and I can do that in MATLAB using
function handles so this is something if
you don't know about you can Google it's
really simple to get used to it so I'm
going to define on the fly a function of
time and Y and that function is a times
y that's it that's the right hand side
function I'm gonna integrate for time in
this vector T from 0 to 10 and I'm gonna
integrate initial conditions Y naught
okay so we have a little more time today
are there questions about OD 45 and
function handles any of this there
probably should be this makes sense how
many of you think you can use OD 45 to
simulate an equation how many of you
don't okay so what you need to know is
how to take your differential equation
and write it as a first order system why
single dots one time derivative equals
some function on the right hand side of
Y okay then you define that function of
Y using function handles and you tell it
how how long you want to integrate for
and what your initial condition is
that's it okay so try it out try it out
for a different system try it for y dot
equals sign of Y just like in that lab
at home try to integrate Y dot equal
sign of Y using this formula okay and
you'll get a hang of how to actually do
it
okay so I've held my plot so I have the
Ellucian in black now i'm gonna plot the
numerical solution in red - and I'll put
up a legend this is my analytic solution
and my oh de 45 solution and I should
probably label time and why label is my
solution X good okay and we see that the
red dash is pretty much perfectly
overlay our analytic solution which is
nice this really is exactly the same
representation as what we had over there
it's just another way of solving it okay
any questions about this Oh de yeah sure
so this y colon comma wine good so what
is y : once so size of Y it's a 501 by 2
matrix which means it has two really big
columns those columns are X and V so
there's a column for X in time and
there's a column for V in time okay so
that's what that's what Y is it's two
columns one for X one for V and I just
want to plot the first column well I
just want to plot the x position okay
okay good we're gonna keep going
okay so now what if we just make this a
little bit different let's make this on
-3 now what changes and I'm going to
change my initial conditions a little
bit okay so now I have X double dot
minus three X dot plus 2x equals zero
with these initial conditions so
physically what just changed what was my
original equation like what does this
kind of physically represent well what
could it physically represents a spring
mass damper
yeah with it with a damper right so this
would be what term the damping term
right this is my frequency term this is
my damping term and earlier I had
positive damping which is good the
universe is built on positive damping
what about when I make damping negative
now so originally my solution decayed
because faster velocities got damped out
more aggressively now faster velocities
are going to accelerate and so this
should go unstable physically we think
they should go unstable okay you should
always have a physical gut feeling for
what your Odie's
are telling you okay this doesn't change
here I just have a bunch of minus signs
now this is minus minus so what's the
solution of this characteristic equation
now we can still factor it so now it's
just lambda minus 2 times lambda minus 1
equals 0
and now instead of being negative my
lambdas are positive and that's my
solution and notice I changed my initial
condition so that I still had the
constants k1 and k2 u equal to 1 I don't
want to solve those systems yeah ok so
if I have negative damping here then I
get positive Exponential's e to the T
and either the 2t and so as T goes to
infinity
blow up to infinity okay my system
should go unstable so physically these
lambdas are giving you kind of growth or
decay constants if they were complex
like you suggested then there would be
some oscillatory component as it either
grows or decays okay
and they're always roots of this
characteristic equation where you take e
to the lambda T you plug it in and you
get these coefficients times powers of
lambda pretty nice clean way of solving
linear systems makes a lot of sense okay
last example so this is I think pretty
relevant for the homework I don't
remember exactly what values I gave but
I think this is pretty close by the way
for the homework I should have told you
you can definitely Taylor expand it at
the point x equals zero that would be
kind of the reasonable Taylor series
expansion okay so let's do a final case
so in the first case we had two negative
eigenvalues which meant that the system
was asymptotically stable asymptotic
means T goes to infinity in the second
example we had positive eigenvalues
because we had negative damping and our
solutions blew up and so now we're going
to have a third case X double dot plus X
dot minus 2x equals zero okay how do I
solve this equation what do I do
okay there's some e to the lambda t what
do I do with it good I take the
derivative once and twice and I plug it
in here and I get a characteristic
equation so my characteristic equation
should be lambda squared plus lambda
minus two times e to the lambda T equals
zero so lambda squared plus lambda minus
two equals zero and how do i factor this
okay minus one like that good thank you
so now we have lambda equals 1 and
lambda equals -2 so this is a little bit
interesting ok now we have one positive
and one negative eigenvalue and so our
solution is going to be something like X
2 X of T equals a constant either the
Maya either the plus T plus another
constant e to the minus 2t and what
could my initial conditions be I'm just
going to again pick really easy initial
conditions X 0 equals 3 and X dot 0
equals 0 which gives me K 1 and K 2
equals 1
okay so what happens to this system what
what does the solution look like for
long times well right so this one decays
this one goes to zero this one goes to
infinity so I have something that's
going to zero plus something that's
going to infinity and so the unstable
term always dominates always if you have
one positive eigenvalue I could have
like a thousandth order differential
equation with a thousand eigenvalues a
thousand roots of this characteristic
equation and if a single one of them is
positive then the solution will blow up
to infinity and beyond stable okay so
this is an unstable system and it goes
to infinity as time goes to infinity now
if I chose a really really really
careful initial condition so that k1 had
the equals zero then the solution would
decay because there wouldn't be anything
in this growth mode okay but almost all
initial conditions if I just randomly
picked an initial condition from a hat
it's almost certainly going to have a
component in both of these directions
and one of them is going to blow up to
infinity okay that's it for second-order
equations are there any questions before
we move on to more abstracts
differential equations so this has been
pretty concrete these have been real
physical systems now we're going to go a
little bit more abstract we're going to
start thinking about generic higher
order differential equations but I'll
try to bring it down to actual examples
okay so
so how do I get a higher order
differential equation like what we have
good examples of X dot equals lambda X
right that would be like bunny
populations or radioactive decay we have
good examples of X double dot plus x
equals zero that's like the harmonic
oscillator what's a good example of like
an X quadruple dot type equation when
would I ever get that so if I had my
spring mass how would I modify this to
make it a fourth order equation so the
dashpot gives me the damping DX tops but
it's still only a second-order equation
for this spring sorry another spring in
a mess okay so now if I have a position
x1 and a position x2 there's you know
out off of equilibrium then I have two
second-order equations one for the first
spring one for the second spring okay
I'm just going to write out what this is
quickly so it's m1 x1 double dot this is
F now this is ma K 1 X 1 plus K 2 x1
minus x2 equals 0 if I mess up a sign
please tell me later I don't think the
signs are off right this is just
figuring out the force balance on each
of these masses in terms of the
displacements and the spring constants
this is two coupled second order linear
differential equations ok so they're
coupled because each one has an X 1 and
X 2 so X 1 must depend on X 2 and X 2
must depend on X 1 that's coupling their
second order because each of these
variables has second order derivatives
and their linear because I don't have
any
powers of like X 1 squared or X 1 times
X 2 it's linear so this might be a
homework question on the next homework
assignment so I'll just tell you one
thing you can do you could write this as
a system for first-order equations by
introducing a variable X 1 dot equals V
1 V 1 dot equals X 2 dot equals V 2 V 2
dot equals okay so this will be one
homework problem is taking these coupled
second order systems and writing them as
for first-order systems for first order
coupled linear equations okay so if you
want to get a jump on next week's
homework try this one or you could write
it as a single fourth order equation and
the way you would do this is you would
solve equation 1 4 X 2 so X 2 is some
function of X 1 and its derivatives then
you would take two derivatives right you
get X double dot of 2 equals the second
derivative f of X 1 and you plug in to
equation 2 so this is the procedure
you can try this over the weekend or
early next week and this will definitely
be on the homework so if I solve
equation 1 for X 2 then X 2 is some
function that has an X 1 double dot in
it right right X 2 is going to equal
like some X 1 double dot plus some other
stuff so then when I take another 2
that x1 double dot becomes an X 1
quadruple dot and so when I plug it in
here I have an X 1 quadruple dot plus
all of this stuff and I have a
fourth-order
single equation okay that's just kind of
the flavor of things so I could take
this and turn it into a system of
first-order equations and solve it in
MATLAB right this is a matrix system of
equations or I could write it as one big
fourth order equation okay and you can
do this well we'll look at this a little
bit more next week and this will
definitely be on the homework
okay so let's say that I had some fourth
order system of equations I had X 1 2 3
4 plus 5 X 1 2 3 plus 2 X double dot
plus X dot plus 7 x equals 0 how would I
solve this differential equation guess
what what's a good guess for a linear
system of linear equation e to the
lambda T ok so x equals e to the lambda
T X dot is lambda e to the lambda T X
double dot is lambda squared e to the
lambda t triple dot has three lambdas
quadruple dot has four lambdas and so on
and so forth right if I took the 590
seventh derivative I have lambda to the
597 either the lambda T okay this works
forever and so I take and plug these in
and I get a higher-order characteristic
equation I get lambda to the fourth from
here plus 5 lambda cubed plus 2 lambda
squared plus lambda plus 7 times e to
the lambda T equals 0 and when can this
possibly equal 0 for any lambda that
solves this polynomial okay so lambda to
the 4th plus 5 lambda cubed plus 2
lambda squared plus lambda plus 7 equals
0 this is my characteristic equation and
how many roots of this polynomial are
there how many unique lambdas are going
to solve this for there's going to be 4
solutions to this equation for lambdas
lambda 1 lambda 2 lambda 3 lambda 4 okay
so there's four solutions what if I had
an X you know a sixth derivative term
here then how many lambdas would there
be six okay so there's four solutions
lambda one lambda
to lambda 3 lambda 4 and my solution X
of T is going to equal some constant 1 e
to the lambda 1 T plus constant 2 e to
the lambda 2 T plus constant 3 e to the
lambda 3 T plus constant 4 e to the
lambda 4 T now how would I get these
constants initial conditions what kind
of initial conditions why need 4 of em
right because I have 4 unknown so I need
to know four things what are some
reasonable initial conditions for this
system for this physical double
spring-mass system yeah so really I'd
like to know the initial position and
velocity of both of the masses that
would be a very reasonable physical
initial condition or if I knew the
initial position and first derivative
and second derivative and third
derivative of one of them I think that
would also work right so if I knew like
you know the position and three
derivatives that would probably also
work here okay so this is extremely
general any higher order differential
equation with any number of derivatives
as long as it's linear you can assume
either the lambda T plug in get this
characteristic equation and solve X in
terms of e to the lambda T's okay if
these lambdas are complex then we're
gonna get sines and cosines if they're
positive real then we get exponential
growth if they're negative real we get
exponential decay okay if they're you
know if lambda equals minus 1 plus I
then I'm going to have an exponentially
decaying envelope and my solutions going
to oscillate as it decays
okay and the velocity will be 90 degrees
out of phase with that so the real and
the imaginary part of e to the I minus
one plus I T yeah I just wanna it's in
my mind part of the process I always go
from here right to here right like once
you get really comfortable with these
you'll recognize every pie every
derivative of X is a power of lambda and
every coefficient just multiplies that
power of lambda so you can go right from
your equation to the characteristic
equation if you like that's fine I
haven't come across anything like that I
can't think of it off the top of my head
it's always good to know when you're
solving something equals zero like there
is another term here and it can't equal
it cannot equal zero okay
so for this equation why don't we try to
write this as a matrix system of for
first-order or linear equations okay
because that's going to be something I
really want us to get good at in the
class because it's going to allow us to
use MATLAB and use linear algebra like
eigen values and eigen vectors and it's
going to be really really helpful in the
future okay so we had X 1 2 3 4 + 5 X 1
2 3 + 2 X double dot plus X dot plus 7 x
equals 0 soon we're going to start
adding forcing to these equations we're
going to start actually you know pumping
energy into the system maybe I can in my
spring mass system maybe I can move the
platform or I can have you know an
electromagnetic adding force or momentum
to this for now we're gonna keep this
homogeneous equals 0 okay so what do I
do to turn this fourth order single
linear linear equation into a system of
four first-order linear equations okay
so I want to introduce dummy variables
so X dot equals V but I need more right
that only gets me okay so V dot is like
X double dot right so let's make a new
dummy variable this is bad let's try X
dot equals Y let's try Y dot equals XYZ
let's try Z dot equals a
a dot equals B okay so we're at X dot
this is kind of like X double dot X
triple dot X fourth okay so this is my X
quadruple dot right a dot and that
equals sorry so X dot X double dot X
triple dot X quadruple dots so a dot
equals x quadruple dot and it equals
minus all of this stuff okay so it
equals minus seven X minus X dot minus
two X double dot minus five x triple dot
okay but I've just taken all of the time
to introduce names for these so X dot is
y X double dot is Z and X triple dot is
a so this is the same as saying DDT of a
vector X Y Z a that's gonna be some
matrix times X Y Z a okay so what is X
dot equal Y okay so it's zero one zero
zero if I multiply this I just get Y y
dot equals Z so that's zero zero one
zero if I multiply that row vector I get
a Z the next one Z double dot is zero
zero sorry Z dot is a and a dot is all
of this stuff right it's minus seven X
minus 1 Y minus two Z and minus five a
this is my matrix linear system of first
order differential equations and the
solutions lambda to my characteristic
equation are the eigenvalues of this so
lambda are eyes
of a pretty cool okay we're gonna look
way more in detail at these linear
systems of equations in terms of the
matrices and the eigenvalues and the
eigenvectors we're going to go way
deeper but I just want to kind of bring
your attention to the fact that we can
always do this any questions so what's
kind of interesting about these
characteristic equations when I have a
second-order differential equation I get
a quadratic in lambda and we can solve
it using the quadratic formula if I have
a cubic or three derivatives I get a
cubic function of lambda and does anyone
remember how to solve a cubic equation
in lambda so there's a method this it's
named after this guy named Cardin oh I
think he must have been Italian if you
had a fourth order equation like this
there is a an analytic expression I
could write lambdas in terms of like
square roots of square roots of all this
nasty stuff
Ferrari invented that
but 4/5 order equations in general if I
had you know 17 X 1 2 3 4 5
there is no analytic closed form
solution two fifth order and higher
polynomials how many of you have heard
of this result before right this is
called the in solve ability of the
quintic and I believe Gauss was the
first person who ever approved this it's
really really hard to prove it's not
that fun to prove either interestingly
enough you can prove it with a ruler
sorry with a straight edge and a compass
you can prove that there are no
closed-form solutions to fifth order and
higher characteristic equations but
what's really neat is that we're able to
take differential equations right this
is calculus rates of change of rates of
change of rates of change we get this
calculus like expression here and we're
able to turn it into a purely algebraic
expression
all we're looking for is roots of a
polynomial or eigen values of the matrix
they're equivalent so the last thing I'm
going to show you in the last two
minutes this is assuming I can get the
screen down there you go so the last
thing I'm going to show you remember we
had this a matrix for our second-order
damped harmonic oscillator and what were
the eigenvalues for that again sorry
what were the lambda that solved that
characteristic equation right we had
minus 1 and minus 2 okay so if I look at
the eigen values of my a matrix I get
exactly the same eigen values well you
can't see sorry these are the
eigenvalues of this a matrix okay so
when I wrote that second-order system as
two coupled first order system equations
the eigenvalues of my a matrix were
exactly the solution the roots of my
characteristic equation so this is
something we can always do numerically
is even if I have a hundred order
characteristic equation I can't write
down analytically the solution I could
write down this hundred by hundred a
matrix and find its eigen values that
will always work okay that's what we're
gonna talk about next week how many of
you have liked have seen eigenvalues and
eigenvectors feel pretty comfortable
with them how many don't feel that
comfortable okay so we're gonna go from
scratch and really understand what these
mean and we're going to get a geometric
interpretation of these differential
equations it's going to be one of the
most powerful things we do okay have a
good weekend
you